[Music]
bloodshot with vin diesel was released
this year just days before the cinemas
around the world closed their doors
therefore the film about the immortal
elite soldier grey garrison performed
badly
at the box office contrary to
expectations however the film was
surprisingly well received
and as a result was very often bought
and viewed via video on demand
which prompted dmg entertainment to
initiate a sequel
in terms of content the nanotechnology
equipped and quasi immortal elite
soldier
will continue to track down his creator
the rst corporation
garrison can heal himself completely by
using the advanced technology
however the ruthless organization also
controls the thoughts and brain of the
killing machine
the groundwork for the film will
probably be once again the comic series
bloodshot but how exactly dmg will
implement the sequel
is not known at this time nor is an
expected release date
last week it was made clear that johnny
depp and warner brothers will go
their separate ways in the future due to
the abuse allegations against his
ex-wife amber heard
meaning that he will no longer be the
actor of the evil wizard grindelwald
financially however this should not
bother him at all as he will still
receive his eight-figure salary
fans reacted mixedly to deb's retirement
on the one hand many fans jump to the
popular active side and criticize warner
brothers
on the other hand others see the
situation a bit more pragmatically and
wonder
who will succeed him if one believes the
magazine deadline there is already a
clear favorite
casino royale villain mats mikkelsen
although nothing has been decided yet
mikkelsen is probably considered the
favorite of director david yates
but they shouldn't take too much time
either because the production of
fantastic
beasts 3 is already in progress should
mickelson be engaged
one can strongly assume that he'll also
play the wizard gellert grindelwald in
the plan parts 4
and 5 of the fantastic beasts series the
us release of the third part is expected
to be on july 15
2022 in fact many fans had already been
looking forward to the mortal kombat
movie which was supposed to release in
the coming march
on twitter producer todd garner now
reached out to the fans with bad news
since the reboot will not be able to
appear as planned due to the cinema
closures
according to garner there will be a new
date only after it is clear when cinemas
can open again
the same applies to a long-awaited
trailer thus mortal kombat judged on
numerous films that they have no release
date since their postponements
it is to be hoped that the production
team will use the time for fine tuning
and will be able to offer the fans an
even better cinema experience in the end
first through the mummy returns and
later the scorpion
king dwayne johnson became known to a
larger audience in the early 2000s
in addition to his work as a wrestler in
the wwe
it seems that the letter is now being
completely reissued the screenplay is
supposed to have been written by a
straight out of compton author
jonathan herrmann while johnson's
company's seven bucks productions
is working with universal on the
production so he is primarily
responsible for the new movie as a
producer the search for suitable leading
actor and director is still in full
swing
so it is unlikely that johnson will be
seen in a leading role in front of the
camera but that's not unusual because
the four scorpion king sequels all have
different leading actors
jeff snyder of collider does not rule
out the possibility that johnson will be
in front of the camera for a short
appearance in his project
when the reboot will be in the cinemas
is not yet foreseeable
but release before 2022 is considered
very unlikely
given the production status those who
would like to see dwayne johnson on the
big screen
soon can also look forward to disney's
latest family adventure
jungle cruise on july 30th 2021
probably nobody expected this on the
first sad photo of the friendly spider
from the neighborhood
spider-man wears two masks at once
namely a mouth nose covering and his
usual suit the message follows directly
below the picture
apart from that not much seems to have
changed since far from home as at first
glance the suit is identical to the one
from the predecessor
not much is known about the content yet
but many fans are looking forward to the
appearance of jamie foxx's bad guy
electro
and benedict cumberbatch as a new mentor
dr strange
dr strange's knowledge of multiverses
could certainly be beneficial to spidey
as the marvel and sony's universe
collide through the appearance of
electro the release date of spider-man 3
is expected to be december 17th
2021 in 2018 the horror thriller a quiet
place turned out to be one of these
surprise hits of the year
the film about the unyielding and
extremely noise sensitive aliens brought
an impressive
341 million on a budget of just
17 million since then fans have been
eagerly awaiting the completion of part
2
which has been postponed several times
due to cinema closures and will now be
released in
april next year the spin-off mentioned
above will no longer be directed by john
krasinski as in the first two parts
but by midnight special director jeff
nichols this time the story will
probably no longer revolve around the
abbott family
but will shed light on the fate of other
people in the post-apocalyptic world
an exact title and details of the
content are not yet known
the release of a quiet place 3 is
reportedly planned for 2022
bye